[Music]
hey what is up guys MP PhD here and we
saw a bunch of new MacBook Pros launched
yesterday and only one of them started
shipping that day and on my hands on
that one the brand new 2013 baseline
MacBook Pro it's the least different of
the bunch that we saw announced but it
is still worth they can look at because
it's one of the best laptops in its form
factor it's super expensive so it should
be but it is one of the best so check
this out this is everything you need to
know that's new with the 2016 13 inch
MacBook Pro like I said obviously it's
not a whole lot new so this will be a
pretty quick easy video also we have
obviously the larger 15-inch MacBook Pro
with the touch bar I'm working on
getting my hands on that as quickly as I
can for a video so stay tuned for that
and we also have the 13-inch MacBook Pro
with a touch bar as well this is neither
of those this is the 13-inch MacBook Pro
baseline cheapest one you can get
without the touch bar so it comes in the
box is pretty standard nothing new it's
the laptop itself and then the charger
underneath a USB type-c charger because
this is the only port you have on this
new MacBook just like the 12 inch but
this time it's more than one port so
that takes me to the first difference
the design this is a slightly new design
and the new MacBook Pros are thinner and
lighter than the last gen and it shows
the new 13-inch is about 15 millimeters
thick and three pounds which is the same
as the MacBook Air and the new 15-inch
is going to be about fifteen and a half
millimeters thick and only four pounds
which is super dense and you can tell
just by looking at them they've
minimized the footprint they've really
packed everything into this metal body
no taper just straight rectangles and
sharp corners and hard lines I'm
actually a fan of this industrial design
there's also now a space gray version
alongside the silver but the difference
is really subtle it's actually not a
black laptop like you might have thought
so difference number two is all the
ports forget all the ports you had on
previous MacBook Pros forget the
full-size USB ports forget HDMI forget
the micro SD card slot forget
Thunderbolt none of that
it's just USB type-c and a headphone
jack so this is a lot this is a
continuation bet from Apple that this is
all we'll need in the future
and I agree about the future but
obviously this is the present so you're
going to need some adapters some dongles
to get it to do what you wanted to do
with previous
Pro machines the 13-inch MacBook Pro has
two USB type-c ports on the side while
the 15-inch has four any of them can be
used for charging that which is nice so
number three big new feature improvement
with these is pretty simple as the new
trackpad so we've had this new force
touch trackpad for a little bit in
previous Mac books and MacBook Pros it's
great this one's just way bigger you can
see it's just this huge surface between
the keyboard and the bottom of the
laptop and obviously having a way bigger
makes these gestures easier when you now
have this huge surface area to work with
and in speaking of the keyboard that is
also new so gone are the chiclet keys
from the MacBook Pros of the past these
are all now rocking the
second-generation butterfly switches
that you might find familiar from the
little 12-inch MacBook these definitely
take some getting used to
there's only a couple millimeters of
travel it's a very low travel keyboard
though not as tactile when typing and I
still personally prefer the old-style
chiclet keys obviously I like more
travel when I get the chance but this is
likely a space-saving decision so
butterfly switches are everywhere now
and this keyboard got that much thinner
and then flanking the keyboard on both
the 13 inch and 15 inch MacBook Pros you
can also see the new speakers this is
also similar to the 12-inch MacBook
which if you remember actually had some
really loud super impressive speakers in
that little body and I have listened to
the new speakers on these new MacBook
Pros and they also sound really really
good so that's at least a bonus even if
you are keeping the headphone jack and
then last but not least is the new
displays so there's still the same
resolution as before so the same Retina
displays the same 13 and 15 inch sizes
but they're now 67 percent brighter have
67% better contrast ratios and show 25%
more color so a wider color gamut now
that's actually a really huge brightness
increase and actually notice that right
away when you're looking at the display
outdoors I don't even have to max out
the display to see it pretty clearly
which is awesome
we'll have to see how this affects
battery life but yeah these new screens
look really good other than that you
have the new chips inside the new
updated specs which all look pretty
great significantly faster flash storage
up to 2 terabytes and Intel's new 6th
generation iSeries chips and everything
else you'll recognize I think it's a
pretty solid upgrade but I am definitely
personally waiting for a maxed out
15-inch MacBook Pro with touch bar and
everything I think I'm convinced I play
with it for less than an hour
that's gonna be my next mobile editing
machine this little guy isn't perfect
obviously no SD card slot is a real
bummer when you're calling it a pro
machine the webcam is still poop quality
sorry that's probably not going to
change anytime soon and there's no more
glowing Apple logo on the back of I
guess any Apple laptops now and the
MagSafe was one of Apple's best
inventions ever in my opinion and that's
gone within a USB type-c charger overall
if you were considering a MacBook Air
even though this one technically doesn't
replace it it's one upping it in every
category so I would consider this over
the MacBook Air for a thin and light
even if it has the word Pro in the name
you can just kind of ignore that so
that's been it that's what you're
getting with the new 13-inch MacBook Pro
let me know what you guys think and
again I'm really pumped for the 15-inch
MacBook Pro I keep saying it I don't
know if I'm overreacting about the touch
bar but I'm a final cut user it looks
sick having a whole timeline in there
there's obviously other things that I'll
have to test with that touch bar
it's got my attention I'm ready for it
either way thanks for watching and I'll
talk to guys the next one peace
[Music]